I've got a bone to pick with you all
also I did a maths a law we're back in
office so I'm back in the office on a
Saturday
I just finished recording the last the
crash course videos because I've got all
of my kit here that's like a studio
setup over there I just spent like five
minutes trying to do an extreme closeup
of an M&M Oh watching if you want to
learn more about how M&Ms could possibly
be the key to stopping global warming
then you should check out my global
warming Ashlee notes the geoengineering
video in my crash course more about that
later in the video for now let's do PhD
watch so you might remember the last
time that I was talking about the fact
that my supervisor told my theory to
shreds tells what I was doing and I was
feeling reasonably okay with that
because I felt like I had a good lead
and I had a few days in the wilderness
so to speak I spent a lot of time with
this textbook over here and it pointed
me in the right direction
so basically oh how am I going to
explain that so the earth is rotating
you know I hope that's not news to you
the earth is spinning right and the the
atmosphere is like fluid on top of it if
in terms of physics fluids means like
liquids gases they obey the same physics
you can still you can use the same
equations to describe them and the
equations that you used to describe them
are really complicated and then if you
put those equations on a rotating sphere
like the earth it just goes mental it's
it's horrible mass so meteorologists and
whatnot II work in using these equations
on the earth like simplifications and
there's a massive massive simplification
you can make called the geostrophic
approximation and what that basically
means is you know how on weather
forecasts do you see pressure maps you
know like you see areas of low pressure
and high pressure and there are lines
which which go everywhere called isobars
which are lines of constant pressure the
G's terrific approximation is basically
that wind will blow along isobars and
you know that's a reasonable
approximation and when it comes to
large-scale stuff
like hurricanes and the polar vortex you
can use that kind of approximation so
for stuff like I'm working on that's a
good starting point basically what I've
been doing at the past couple days is
assuming that that approximation is
nearly right like you basically write
that the wind velocity at a given point
is equal to that geostrophic velocities
like the velocity assuming that it just
goes along I suppose
that plus a small extra factor and then
what you do is you take that expression
for the velocity and put that into your
equations of motion for fluid on a
rotating sphere and then you can get
depending on what you're looking for you
can get different results out and
basically what I did was there's some
horrible then if you're actually able to
see that but like some pretty pretty
dense algebra I basically got to the
point where I now have an expression for
the rate of change of pressure over the
polar cap which is what I'm interested
in using this almost geostrophic
approximation it's called a quasi GS
terrific approximation if you understand
really wanky and I feel quite proud of
that so I'm gonna take that to my
supervisor in the coming week and have
that to a part and then start again and
then eventually we'll get somewhere
we'll get somewhere where it's actually
solid and you can hit it with an
academic sledgehammer and it will stay
standing but yeah I might actually have
something to present the conference in
San Francisco this December so yay right
now going back to what I said at the
start the video I've got a bone to pick
with you I mean we need to talk there's
something I want to talk to you about
and his name is Josh
it's not John Cena I want to talk to you
about the videos that are coming out on
this channel at the moment so as of the
moment this channel has about twenty two
thousand subscribers which I am
incredibly proud of it literally boggles
my mind that that many people are
interested in the stuff I make but as it
turns out they're not because when I put
a vlog up like this I anticipate that
this will get a few thousand views
within a couple of days then the last
look did that people are interested in
watching those I've been putting up my
crash course in atmospheric physics
recently and that started out with a
good number of views and that's been
going down over time I totally get that
I totally understand that people it's
not for everyone it's not everyone's cup
of tea they're not necessarily
interested in long-form educational
content if they are receiving the videos
basically I need to know are you guys
actually getting my videos in your sub
box because either people aren't
interested in the content which I'm
putting out just fine
or they're not receiving it in the first
place and I need to know so please do
comment below if you're getting these
videos and if you are getting the videos
and you're not interested I want you to
be really honest with me and tell me why
you're not interested because to me it
boggles my mind that I can put up a
short video like a five-minute video on
global warming it's it was less no it's
a three minute briefing on global
warming everybody has three minutes and
is the most important issue in the world
I can't think of a single thing which is
as important as global warming so for
people to say that they're not
interested in that I just don't
understand that point of view so I want
you to tell me why you're not interested
if you're not and you know please be
brutally honest with me and you know if
this is a wake-up call for you and you
didn't know that they were out there
please go and watch them because I think
they're incredibly important it's just
quite disheartening really when you're
putting out content that you literally
put so much work into the stuff that's
mean that there are more videos coming
out on this channel in the past month
then you know appeared in an entire year
before I have put so much work into into
this channel and the content which I'm
passionate about and it's it's just a
bit disheartening when people don't
engage with it people don't watch it and
also if you do watch it please don't
comment on things that are unimportant
like what I like or what I'm wearing
because frankly I'm talking about the
most important issue in the world and
why are you interested in what top I'm
wearing like sorry I just need to get it
out I would like to take this
opportunity to say thank you to
everybody who has been watching the
videos and particularly to those people
who have been supporting them on Connors
I've had some really generous donations
thank you so much people who donated to
me I'm gonna put that money towards a
new green-screen a new tripod because
this whole thing this is like falling
apart so I need a new one you know all
the stuff that goes into the Connors
page is gonna go into trying to make my
videos better whether that's hardware or
software so thank you very much to
people who donated I cannot tell you how
appreciative I am that people think my
content is important enough to actually
warrant like supporting more than a ting
I'd like to appeal to everybody who's
watching this video I'm putting out
videos at the moment about the cop21
meeting in Paris which is the global
warming meeting basically in Paris this
year I've interviewed a whole bunch of
different people from X D University
these people are world leading academics
and this is one of the most important
meetings in a history of global warming
I've almost said the world then but like
that's not too far of a stretch to say
because this the Paris meetings if we
unfortunate agreement now we are saving
ourselves trillions of dollars of damage
and potentially millions of lives down
the line you know in terms of understand
this this could be one of the most
important like the key turning points in
human history and I think it's so
important that people learn about it
thank you to everybody who has been and
I'm sorry well this has been a really
wine involved but it's been a little bit
of heartening when like all the work
I've been putting in doesn't seem to be
getting much traction so sorry sorry for
waiting
thank you for watching this video if you
know people who would be interested in
the global warming stuff that I'm
putting out and the science on the crash
course and all that kind of stuff please
please share those videos because
because you know I want to do more them
in the future but I don't feel like I
can if they're not getting a good
response if people aren't paying
attention or if people don't think
they're good then I went do any more so
please do share them if you think might
be interested thank you for watching
there's gonna be more videos about cop
and global warming coming out soon and
then the vlogs from America and the
Darul videos a project for awesome stage
hit next vlog I'll talk more about
project for awesome because that's
really really important yeah thank you
for watching
grams are like subscribe and peace and
oh I feel like a sigh okay so here's my
work but it's important we're good it's
a book I like books and it's got to work
in that's my laptop which has got the
scripts with crash course videos in
that's my Japanese peace lily always
important to keep that around because it
keeps the our oxygenated this is not the
time to introduce science it's
interesting thing but it's off believe
it you know when you're in a negotiation
say you're buying a t-shirt or market
stuff